[Music]
well there it is
my beloved california absolutely
blanketed by smoke
somehow both apocalyptic and beautiful
at the same time
some would say it's not the best idea to
head right into this
least of all during a freaking pandemic
[Music]
but here i am with my mass collection
double pumps of hand sanitizer and my rv
bubble
that contains these two fine companions
like me they've been tested layered with
protocols
and chosen to interact with the world
our mission is to head out on route 395.
it's a road that runs down california's
eastern spine
and that offers up unfair amounts of
spectacular sights
the kinds of things that still produce
wonder amid a smoky haze
i mean come on
along the way we'll be visiting some of
the tech world's outliers
people that like to live and work on the
frontier
they're folks trying to feed the planet
fix it
or if need be just get off it
if thinking different is your thing then
here we go
show us the way rented rv with your
included dashboard ornament
show us the way
we're going 45 and a 70.
is that as fast as it goes
if you're gonna drive an rv through a
fiery hellscape during a pandemic
you want to be sure and do it right
alongside a massive
active fault system in this case may i
present
the walker lane which is often found
hugging
route 395.
while not as well known as say the san
andreas fault it's the walker lane that
gives 395 much of its charm
we're talking hot springs extinct
volcanoes
and mountains and we're talking more
apocalypse
because it's now thought that the walker
lane may result in reno
ending up as a beach town
[Music]
who predicts such things well for one
this man geologist james faults
who forced me to climb this hill near
reno to learn about the fault
we are in the middle of the uh what's
called the walker lane
it's a big belt of faults in western
nevada
also eastern california the san andreas
accommodates about
80 percent of the motion between the
pacific and north american plates
and about 20 maybe as much as 25 of that
motion is over here on
on the walker lane folds is one of a
growing number of geologists who have
become obsessed by the walker lane fault
and what it could mean for residents of
california and nevada in the distant
future
people focus so much on the san andreas
fault and what this could mean and
in 10 million years to the geography of
the united states and california
but i mean there is the potential that
this fault could be
more even more dramatic if some of these
theories are right
we know the walker lane is growing
northward along with the san andreas
so they're scheduled to meet somewhere
off the southern oregon coast in about
maybe seven or eight million years and
what what does that look like
well when that happens what some of us
think
will occur is that the entire san
andreas then will sort of rip up through
the
uh western part of north america or the
we are the u.s
and it'll strand california off to the
west i mean the pacific ocean ends up
kind of rushing through parts of nevada
right well
or is that yeah this is controversial
it'll be a slow process but we may have
beachfront property in reno someday
this fault also sort of brings along
some opportunities right we have these
crustal motions
in the region and in nevada there's a
stretching of the crust
stretching in the horizontal dimension
and that helps to kind of
dilate or open up faults and that brings
hot water up closer to the surface
and then that can be tapped for
geothermal energy
[Music]
what's that jim did you say geothermal
energy
well then let's have a brief musical
interlude
as we gaze upon the nearby geothermal
plant a vormont
it's got everything awesome fans i mean
really awesome fans wells that tap into
geothermal brine
10 000 feet underground sweet sweet
pipes and transmission lines turbines
that you can't really see on either side
of this generator
enough juice for 22 000 homes
the walker lane fault in action back to
you
jim and then part of the reason
there was any controversy or we didn't
even know that much
about this fault was was 20 years ago
was much harder to gather data about
this kind of thing the fault wasn't as
clear
uh when you look down and so what is
this device
this is a gps station so it's actually
communicating with satellites
its position is changing through time
and those satellites are tracking
those changes down to the scale of
millimeters how many are monitoring the
fault there's 400 of these sensors in
this region in a
network called magnets these stations
allow us to sort of focus in on maybe
what what the most important part of the
region
might be like how much activity
[Music]
are people around here seeing as a
result of the fault nevada is the third
third most seismically active state
after alaska and california
[Music]
after our chat james drove off and left
me with that unique brand of existential
dread
that comes from learning about the
perils of your surroundings
and what will befall humankind
to get rid of all that i had only one
option
a night spent at the splendid grand
sierra resort and casino rv park
where as it turns out you can still get
doordash
and eat your sorrows away
[Music]
all right let's see what it says to find
jp google maps will get you close to the
mailbox but not exactly there
expect a long gravel driveway
you got it yeah
from reno we headed south to carson city
well
like the outermost edge of carson city
where an old friend
is engineering a most unique existence
today we're a little bit outside of
carson city nevada
going to the house of jb stravel
he's a guy i've known for a long time he
was one of the first employees
at tesla and the long time chief
technology officer
i always thought of him as the heart and
soul of tesla because he was this guy
who even before tesla was a real thing
he was obsessed
with solar-powered cars with taking
lithium-ion batteries and using them to
one day reshape
the automotive industry he was kind of
the dreamer behind the technology
in the whole electric car revolution a
couple years ago
he decided he was going to go out on his
own
and start a new company around recycling
all these lithium-ion batteries that he
helped create
we're going to learn a little bit more
about his life and then we're going to
go
see his new factory as well what's that
model three
yeah there's one tesla two teslas
three in the back hey guys
how are you i'm good
thanks for letting us do all this you've
like always
constantly got some project going on at
home or one or another
i mean i i love building things and you
know i kind of do this sort of stuff to
relax
this is the current project yeah this is
just
sort of a side fun project but it's a
you know an interesting experiment and
being able to do this you know cheaply
and quickly and find ways to deploy
solar without
heavy equipment and it's just fun and
then even though you ran tesla's energy
division
you still want to you're building your
own battery pack right
it's i don't know i find more fun in the
process you know it's
you can pay someone to do something and
then it's just done and
but uh i think it's almost more the
journey and the you know the mental
exercise of thinking through it
jb started coming out here as tesla
began building its massive gigafactory
battery plant
year by year the charms of nevada grew
on him and he decided to stop living in
hotels
and take over this fine compound
over the years elon musk has gotten all
of the tesla love in adoration
meanwhile jb quietly did his thing in
the background
always a tinkerer and engineer at heart
he spearheaded many of tesla's key
projects
before leaving the company in 2019
you come from a long line of of
tinkerers
tell me tell me a little bit about your
dad and your grandparents and
my great-grandfather actually uh you
know immigrated here
from germany and uh started uh an engine
company
in green bay wisconsin and they you know
he actually built machine some of the
very first internal combustion engines
for boats back then for fishing boats
i mean it must be in the blood to some
degree because i know i mean you were
tinkering from
like what when you were a teenager or
even before that i just enjoy it you
know it doesn't it
wasn't necessarily a you know a means to
an end it was just something fun to do
and
building things taking stuff apart it's
yeah it's what i do for fun
even in the early days i still remember
my dad taking me on
you know tours of power plants when i
was you know like this tall and didn't
know quite what i was looking at but i
thought it was all super cool and i
actually really loved chemistry in high
school that was
probably my favorite subject back then
and you know i had built a whole
chemistry lab in the basement
and was you know trying to learn about
all that on my own and understand you
know
batteries and electrochemistry stuff uh
even back then
you went to stanford and at stanford you
worked on
obviously this carried over because you
end up working on on the solar
racing team and and i mean did you feel
like there was a revolution coming or
this was just something that was
interesting
to you well it it felt early
you know it was you know things hadn't
taken off and it was very um
you know almost contrarian a little bit
thinking about solar and solar
car racing and this kind of stuff i had
an inkling that we were kind of at the
beginning of that transition and you
could clearly see the potential
overlapping into the end of that is when
you know i i was spending much more time
you know really digging into you know
the earliest days of electric vehicles
and starting to think more about
lithium-ion batteries
and the solar car racing stuff was was
really the first
you know on-road application of anything
like that at some point there was a race
and and the team ends up crashing
at your house and this is right when the
lithium-ion
batteries are turning up and all these
consumer electronic devices
you tell my story wasn't this like the
moment where you guys were like maybe we
could lash all these things
together and i was actually living in
los angeles at the time in glendale
and it was only a few miles away from
where the race ended i called my buddies
and was like oh come on over it's fun
you know let's
we'll hang out and you can all crash in
the living room we ended up you know
staying up you know
most of the night you know reminiscing
about the race and talking about the
technology and how it worked and and you
know hatched this crazy project you know
to um
to build you know a long-range electric
car
ditch the solar panels and just see if
we could drive you know almost a
thousand miles on
on electricity alone it really i just
fell in love with it and it
you know was such a fun project it just
felt like it had to be done
you know i saw no one else doing it and
wanted to throw myself into it
and in those days southern california
was kind of you know the mecca for
you know the early stages of electro
electric cars and batteries
so it was a good place to be
you end up with this guy martin eberhard
and mark tyberning they want to make an
an all-electric sports car you've got
elon
down in la he he's also kind of
interested in this idea and happens to
have
a lot of money and and eventually these
forces
combine and then and then you're right
there at the very beginning as well
they're some of the best times you're
thinking back on it but it also
you know we had no idea what we were up
against you know and trying to imagine
what it would become
um it was just a handful of people yeah
and you know no one had ever tried this
stuff before and
that was the beginning of you know how
we started to understand
large format batteries and how to
architect the safety of
of that and so that was the challenge
right i mean it was you guys were
worried about obviously
fires and then like how you cool these
things and there were
explosions in the neighborhood
well it was it was a lot of trial and
error i mean we were fearless and we
just you know
plunge into this and you know knowing
that somehow we'd figure this stuff out
but uh yeah i mean that we kind of built
it off the experience that came out of
even those earliest solar car
experiments but scaled it way up yeah
and had
you know the support of a growing
engineering team and uh
you know more and more interest and
focus to really you know create what
became you know the roadster
[Music]
well this is a this is a really old
roadster this was actually one of our
first engineering prototypes engineering
prototype five is what we called it
so a little bit before we started series
production you know years ago we
refurbished it and uh
i sort of collected this thing and i've
taken care of it since
i believe it's the oldest tesla that's
on the road still does it give you
like ptsd or only
only fond memories it's it's a great
thing to you know get in there and
remember
what evs you know were like not that
long ago and it's incredible how fast
the development has happened
these days jb is all about batteries and
what we should do with them
he left tesla to start redwood materials
at its heart
it's a battery recycling company but
looked at another way
it's sort of like a lithium or nickel
mine just in reverse
sort of a startling amount of phones
this is
a big bit of phones man well yes
one of many redwood has a lot of
batteries
i believe the technical term is a ton
consumers send them in so do companies
this is basically some of the incoming
material that we get you know from
consumers so
you know it's a whole variety of stuff
just 18650s
scooter battery pack even you know power
tool battery packs it's like a power
pack thing
you know but this has a battery in it so
you know it's difficult to dispose of
and we can recycle this for the
materials
we're inventing the ways you know that
you can basically recycle this without
having a human do it because
it's too small how much lithium that's
been used in here would you guys be able
to recover
like what's the reuse percentage almost
all of it you know lithium maybe
more than 80 percent nickel 95
98 same with cobalt um and copper
so you know it's a pretty complete
process
[Music]
redwood gets devices takes out the
batteries and then begins breaking them
down into their elemental parts
this is largely done through heat
serious heat
which is why these space men are needed
they're using an oven to create what is
basically metal magma
which then goes into a tub and is
stirred with a rake
because why not redwood then goes
through chemical and other processes
to end up here mounds of stuff that was
once pulled from the ground
and can now be reused
so we got some more metal over here yeah
this is just a
a small batch of lithium carbonate that
we just made this morning and
this is sort of a chance to see you know
what the the final product is and what
lithium actually looks like you know
once you extract it from the batteries
and separate it out
so you know this stuff is is quite pure
lithium carbonate so this is actually
the the input precursor
of how lithium gets you know used and
built back into batteries
it is pretty neat to see it separated
like this and uh
you know know that this came from
batteries you know that were you know
otherwise you know garbage and otherwise
wouldn't have been recovered
i mean it's like the lithium say it's
been in my phone
and you guys refine it how many times
can that
happen can this just keep going on and
on and on
there's no there's no real limit to it
there's no degradation that happens to
those atoms of lithium or cobalt or
nickel
and it's one of the coolest things about
this is that those metals are basically
infinitely recyclable
except for the small amounts that get
lost in the recycling process
itself you can basically keep doing that
again and again and again
so you can start to imagine a future
where you're thinking huh like if we can
do this
a thousand times you know the need for
mining new materials
starts to dwindle that's cool
after a hard day of alchemy jb will head
home and tend to his nerd garden
that might mean expanding the solar farm
or fiddling with his homemade
mountaintop
internet repeaters
or obviously letting that still running
sexy yellow roadster loose
remember kids study hard work hard
find a super rich friend with a mars
fetish who believes in electric cars
just as much as you do
and this can all be yours too
[Music]
if you visit california you might be
inclined to go to disneyland
or jump in your convertible and take
highway 1 up the coast
or maybe make a pilgrimage to yosemite
all very fine choices but if you're the
kind of person who revels in our
planet's extremes
then it's route 395 that you're after
this one glorious road will carry you
from death valley's desert floor
to sky-high views of mount whitney
you can see the 5 000 year old
bristlecone pines
the oldest living organisms
or the bizarre tufa towers of mono lake
and true to california's boom and bust
spirit
you can saunter around the ghost town of
bodhi
what a novel experience to find an empty
american city
where all the businesses are shut down
to do 395 upright it helps to have a
guide
and mine is a man named yawn
the hardest partying dog of all time
jan agreed to show me some of what 395
has to offer
but only if we agreed not to disclose
any locations
[Music]
my name is jan sorostra i'm an
industrial designer out of la
and uh i spent a lot of time camping and
a lot of time in the eastern sierra
it's a place i love and sometimes i'm
known
as 395 north because instagram this yep
my instagram account and i don't like to
be known as that
but i'm trying to use it to set a good
example
and do more with it than just social
media
[Music]
where did we end up camping we got here
lately i wasn't even
sure where we are this is uh blm land
right on the outskirts of national
forest and uh it's
one of my favorite places in the world
basically
everything outdoors wrapped into one yep
yeah good thing about california man
oh man we have so much national forest
and public land
yeah that you can literally just cruise
out
and find a place to camp it's ours
what i wish was mine is yawn's sweet
truck it's a uh 2019 ford ranger
has about 200 watts of solar in it and
a fridge and has everything
that an rv has except for a toilet yeah
but just on a smaller
simple scale you drive us around day to
day in la
yep and then just roll out when you want
it's my daily driver um
handle's great and then when i'm done
with work i can just
bale and go camping so the camper
basically
has only what i need think of it as
backpacking with a car
yeah the fridge has a couple
compartments
this is just a kitchen box stove
utensils and a bunch of stuff
this one has uh just dry food then when
you get inside there's a bed
the bed flips up so you've got tons of
room in here
this awning
is phenomenal
if you want to pull that over
that's cool let me just pop that up
sorted so home on wheels yeah this is my
vacation house it was so nice man
even with his nomad lifestyle yan faces
the same big question as the rest of us
do the internet and smartphones have to
ruin everything
when you find the super special
beautiful spots is that
you busting out a map and like looking
where might be cool to go or is it word
of mouth
and just getting to know people all the
locals and if i see a dirt road i just
want to go down
so a lot of it's just aimless rambling
um it's a desire to just see something
check that out
for some reason it's more fulfilling
than getting a recommendation from
somebody or
there's tons of apps and websites now
road trip apps camping apps
they've proliferated the knowledge is
accessible on the internet right
i used to fight the geotags
and and i would get really pissed off
like why are you posting this place it's
going to blow up it's going to get
trashed
now i've realized that you you can't
fight it the internet has just shrunk
the world
so we're not going to stop it we're not
going to stop people from
going there so i'm a lot more focused
in conversation now with trying to set a
good example
when you go pick up your trash when
you're
pooping out in the wilderness don't
leave your toilet paper on the top
you know make sure you follow you know
good steps for leaving no trace
as a thank you for this quick guide to
pooping etiquette
we made yon heron and lemmy some tacos
and we all took in the night sky and
knocked back a couple of drinks
take that apocalypse
the thing about good times and serenity
in 2020
is that they're fleeting at best after
we split up from yawn and continued on
our way
smoke started to envelop us
[Music]
the plus side was that our rv no longer
smelled like feet
the downside was breathing
my man david here suggested that we try
and outflank the smoke by cutting
through yosemite
without a reservation we had to talk our
way in uh yes no stopping no getting out
and yeah don't go in the valley yeah
nope no problem we just yeah we just
wanted to get through
it was a beautiful choice glad we got
out of the
whoa okay but not quite as effective as
we had hoped
[Music]
fast forward four hours or so and we had
managed to trade the smoky majesty of
yosemite
for the smoky uh look at it
strip malls of the central valley
we have made it sort of out of the smoke
all the way
across yosemite national park and here
to the gorgeous central valley of
california
we're off to see a kind of surprising
tech startup
that is making some pretty strange
machines
to serve all the growers out in this
[Music]
region
and where would you wear here and this
near fresno this is
california farm country right we're just
south of fresno a town called kingsburg
so we're right in the central valley of
california
very very large farming valley here
it's kind of considered the bread basket
of of the world
the central valley stretches out over
about twenty thousand square miles
and the farmers here produce about
one-fourth of the food that americans
eat
including a whole lot of fruits and nuts
tell me a little bit of the background
of of gus i know some of this is like a
family business the the roots of this go
back
always tell me kind of like how we we
got to what's essentially like a startup
i guess
yeah definitely so the founder of our
company is dave crinklaw
and he started the business back in
1982.
he started with is basically with his
dad
was commercial spraying of trees and
vineyards
got to the point where our biggest
challenge was
labor um just the shortage of it really
he was forced into innovating
and he had had this idea for quite some
time about doing a
driverless sprayer and it
finally got to the point where he said
you know what i either got to get out of
this business
or i'm going to innovate organic or not
crops need to be sprayed
and this process has to take place a few
times a year
this means hiring a lot of people to
work long hours under serious pressure
and so just like the tech bros to the
north
gus decided to solve all of its problems
with robots
on those like labor points you guys have
set this
up where you can have somebody in a
truck and and that one person can
monitor
i think like eight of these in order to
operate gus you have one guy
or girl that sits in a pickup and they
monitor from a laptop computer
so that person is basically just
watching all the vehicles
on the screen they can monitor up to
eight of them at a time
while they're out there spraying in the
orchard and so
that user interface really provides them
with all the information they need to
make sure that the machines are safe
and that they're doing the correct job
so it tells them what speed they're
driving
the engine rpm the amount of gallonage
per acre that they're applying
at any given time so if any one of the
machines has an issue
it's going to send an alert to that
laptop much like a self-driving car
these beasts use gps lidar and cameras
to see
and navigate the world around them they
also rely on pre-built maps of the
orchards for extra guidance
gus builds the machines right here
and then takes them out for robot
training on this orchard next door
it's here that the company learns if the
machines will behave
and do as their software and human
masters command
so this so this is kind of like the this
is a test orchard where you guys
put it through the paces and work on the
technology yeah so this is our
our test orchard right here it's right
by our building as you can see in the
background
so every new machine as it comes off the
assembly line
it's put through a commissioning test
right here we test all the sensors on
the machine autonomous computer
all the safety systems make sure it's
doing what it's doing
prior to when it's delivered to a
customer
so what's it doing now so right now he's
doing a test spray
so he's just turning the water on to
make sure that the system comes up to
pressure
spraying water out of the nozzles just
to make sure it's all functioning
properly
okay it's got like a crazy turbine at
the back
yeah so it's basically just a big fan
okay and that fan's driven off of
the cummins diesel motor and it just
basically creates a big airflow
gus is already selling these vehicles to
brave modern farmers
and people the world over have taken
notice of its machines
and if you just sold them in the central
valley or like throughout the us or even
overseas or where like where are they
going yeah so
right now the majority of our machines
are here in california in the central
valley
however we do have machines and
customers in florida
and the citrus industry over there as
well as australia and i think you
started selling them in like december of
2019
yeah so we started taking orders early
last year for the sprayers and the first
deliveries
we made were in december of 2019. okay
and they how much do they cost
each um so our our retail price on these
machines is 285 thousand dollars so it's
like it's not a small
investment but i'm sure the regular
sprayers aren't aren't
yeah i mean we're honestly not too far
away from conventional equipment on our
price
and the main thing is is that the return
on investment is very
very quick due to all the labor savings
and the increased efficiency i mean
these machines
they just they just drive but basically
what we're doing besides this machine
this is our
our first machine we call it orchard gus
mainly designed for your
your nut trees as well as citrus and
fruit in the future we're working on a
few other projects
we're going to do more machines one of
them is actually a vineyard sprayer so
vineyards are much tighter spacing so
the machine has to be
physically smaller and then we've got
our eyes on doing a lot of other
innovating
that right there friends is a central
valley farmer putting his whole fruit
basket on the table
gary's ted talk can't be far off
and with that it was time to get back in
the rv
and to confront what happens when three
men
are bested by their own failings
and the forces of entropy
[Music]
ah the perks of rv life
[Music]
it's late at night you're tired
you spot a desert campground
pull in and set up shop
buttons are pushed to pop out your
pop-outs
[Music]
a once cram disaster zone becomes
livable for a while
and best of all you've blindly stumbled
onto somewhere like red rock canyon
and well it has much to offer and many
ways to soothe your soul
also steaks
[Music]
make a couple rib eyes some mac and
cheese
it's like our first real food we've had
it's not a sandwich
[Music]
david nicholson ladies and gentlemen
hello world director
we've got vegetables mom
[Music]
this is good
[Music]
re-energized by kraft's top
powderologists in some instant coffee
[Music]
we make our move toward the city of
mojave one of my favorite places in the
world
it's the home to the great windmill
forests
[Music]
to neighborhoods full of hard-working
and possibly hard-living
people and most notably
to aerospace adventurers of all stripes
for decades the mojave air and spaceport
has been the place where you test out
weird new crafts
either supersonic jets or space planes
the folks i want to see are as mojave as
it gets
and they have set their sights on the
moon
we're off to see mast in space which i
guess you could consider
a startup in the new space industry
except they've been here
at the mojave airport for about 15 or 16
years
it's a fascinating company
mast in space was founded in 2004 by
this guy
dave maston it is said that he is shy
or elusive or both so here i am with
this guy
sean mahoney the longtime ceo of mastin
this is where madison started yeah this
was the
original building we've reconfigured
things but
um it was a garage rocket
company literally in the garage
very hands-on gritty get it done
rather than the you know white lab coat
kind of thing
[Music]
over the years mastin has built up a
reputation as a great place for young
hungry engineers
to get their hands dirty with aerospace
technology
we're talking small teams of five or six
people
building things like this
that's zombie it's not the prettiest
spacecraft
but it proved that you could take off
vertically cut the engine
re-light it and land
this all happened back in 2010 well
before spacex was landing rockets
and it caught the attention of one elon
musk
that is a phenomenal email and it's
glad to have helped inspire
[Laughter]
now today mastin has got
over 600 flight operations under our
belt with
these type vehicles no one else
has done 600 rocket landing operations
period what sean will not say is this
for years maston has lived hand to mouth
going from one small contract to another
it hasn't been the best run or frankly
most viable business
in fact mast and kind of became known
for getting passed by by the likes of
spacex
rocket lab and others
which is why it was quite the surprise
when nasa decided to give this tiny
outfit
80 million dollars this year to build a
lunar lander
maston has a series of instruments that
nasa has
selected that we are going to deliver to
the south pole of the moon in december
of 2022 that's that's soon that is soon
and so after a decade of building blocks
and iterations
it's now go time
we're purchasing the ride to
point us at the moon so inside of a
spacex friday
yeah and then our craft will do the
corrections
bring us in put us on the surface and i
think it's gonna fly nine scientific
apparatus is that right we've got
instruments that are going to be
trying to scan the surface of the moon
from on the lander itself
but being able to execute that landing
is
going to be the tricky part and we've
got a couple different landing sites
that we're still kind of looking at
despite the massive contract mastin's
digs are as humble as ever
and it's grit still very gritty are
these guys getting ready for something
this is a small rocket engine test rig
okay
this is where we learn and practice and
get that real world experience that's
not the stuff that's in the textbook
one of the beautiful things about
operating in mojave
we have a test site on the other end of
the airport you hook it up
you drive it out you do the test there's
no getting on the plane
there's no shipping it's right here
[Music]
part of the story of mastin and being
out here and
being this hands-on place is like things
aren't things weren't always
great right because you're you're
dependent on a contract here and there
and so what's it been like keeping the
business running
all this time it's been a challenge
we will look at a project we'll do an
estimate and we'll say great we'll do it
for this amount
so when things go over it's on us
[Music]
the market while there is commercial
customers
the reality is there's still government
dollars that are really the major driver
now with nasa kind of as the anchor
customer for some of these missions
there's a market that's established and
in a
broader sense these next five years
are going to set the standards
for humanity's expansion beyond the
planet
we will return american astronauts to
the moon for the first time since
1972 for long-term exploration
and use the current administration is
super into the moon and i mean for you
guys this has all been pretty
fortuitous yeah look the moon is a topic
of
international discussion and debates
eventually human beings will draw the
moon
into our economic sphere of influence
that is
where humanity will be and so
the ones who get there to establish the
services whether it's communication
whether it's transportation interfaces
or
any of these things the people who are
doing it will get the chance to set
those things
now well i see elon's elon's now that
there's
money out there he's suddenly interested
in the mood as well so yeah
so and that's been it is really cool to
see
the thing that you've been working on
become popular but
really elon is very focused on mars
let's go to the moon first you didn't
say anything about the shirt man
i noticed immediately and i greatly
appreciate it
is the is the lander like sitting in a
one of these warehouses or
like what stage are we so we do have
some hardware that's already
coming in probably middle of next year
is when you will have an actual thing
together and this will be getting
information from the moon
where artemis is planning to land humans
[Music]
mastin's survival seems assured for now
that's not always the case here in
mojave
other space startups like x-core have
gone by the wayside
and companies like virgin have spent
more than 500 million dollars trying to
reach orbit
with little success
the biggest risk takers though are
humans like elliot here
because he's a test pilot who volunteers
to put his life
on the line
the last time i saw elliot was right
after that crash
way back in 2016. he sat for an
interview
to be the pilot for that test they're
not skills you can like just go get
even took me flying there's a couple big
bumps out there today
yeah he never let on that it was his
first time back in a plane after the
wreck
or that he was still wounded and uneasy
because i'm a jerk i asked elliot to
take me to the scene of the crash
the famed mojave boneyard where planes
go
to decompose tell me about this crash
we were testing out a plane and i mean
tell me tell me what happened
so this opportunity came out where a
small jet engine company
was looking for somebody to debut their
engine
we flew the airplane successfully two
times and then the third flight we had
an engine failure
and i ended up weaving my way between
the tails of the 747s here in the
boneyard
until i could find a soft spot to put it
down
at the end of the day you know the
engine that failed was a prototype
engine
uh so you know we i knew the risks that
i was getting into
you walked away but you must have been
shaking for a while
after that yeah i mean obviously if
you're if you don't walk out of that and
think
uh about what you're doing with your
life you're actually probably have
problems but um
i was flying again within a few days of
the accident and testing it right
another
major incident in an airplane an
emergency landing within a week of that
uh that one so so you know get back up
on the horse
have you considered shirtless beach
volleyball
not till this moment
[Applause]
unlike many test pilots with military
training
elliot is actually an engineer who's had
to work his way up
into the test pilot game there's
basically two paths to flight tests
one is you go be a fighter pilot then
you go from fighter pilot to test pilot
the other is you go spend 10 15 years
with a small company and you work your
way from like an engineer
to make that jump to the left seat i was
i still if it's about your story man i
mean so you've got you've got the guys
you're seeing top gun
and that's kind of who you're competing
against somebody's got a new plane
and then you got to go up against the
top gun guy and explain to these people
why you should
fly the plane yeah fundamentally
remember we lost a program to an
astronaut i never even like made a
counter point right
now that i've been in this business for
a while like the science as an engineer
is fascinating right like
you go and learn something in school you
can read it in a book you can see how
the equation works but until you can
like feel it in your hand and see how
that all adds up to
whether it is or is not what you want
from an airplane that's a whole nother
level
and as a test pilot i've flown 80
different kinds of airplanes
successfully
i've got 11 first flights so that means
you're like the first person to take the
machine up
yeah mojave's had this mythic
status you know if this is where you
come to do the most
groundbreaking work and to push machines
to their edge i mean is that is that
still the case
i think there's no question that mojave
is absolutely on the radar right now i
mean there's
the whole world's watching to see what
comes out of mojave this is very
desolate land where you can play and do
things you can't do other places on the
planet
and it attracts like big ego dudes like
you know frontal lobe
kind of guys and to be able to get a
bunch of smart dudes pointing the same
direction go make something fly that
doesn't look like it should
that's a hard thing and it's very
rewarding when it works and when it
doesn't you can spend
an eternity thinking about all how it
all added up against you
[Music]
and so here we are pandemic
fires the overall madness of 2020
which feels more and more like a work of
experimental daddiest art
and yet somehow i end up in the back of
a pickup truck
driving through a plane graveyard during
a mojave sunset
it's not perfect because perfect can't
exist right now
but i gotta tell you it ain't bad
you